in an important question could you fall
victim to a sophisticated Bank scam that
begins with a simple text message the
government says scams of all kinds are
soaring Americans reported losing nearly
8.8 billion dollars to fraud last year
that's up 30 percent from the year
before our consumer investigative
correspondent Anna Warner shows us how
scammers stole a staggering sum from one
woman's bank account and a good morning
this was a lot of money
yeah good morning and you know we've all
gotten those texts from our bank saying
did you make a particular purchase well
next time you'll probably want to read
it again and think before you respond
and the woman you're about to meet can
tell you why
it's got a lot of cheese on it Deborah
Moss has spent more than a decade
running her small catering business
in 2021 she says she'd finally saved
enough money to slow down and move to
rural Guerneville California I'm not a
young person anymore I really was
relying on just kind of a comfortable
life at my age but a few weeks after
moving in she says she got a text saying
her bank Chase wanted to know if she'd
approved a 35 debit card charge from
another state so basically it's one of
those fraud texts did you approve this
transaction yeah that's all it was just
a minor irritant in my day and of course
I said no I don't approve of it then the
phone rang showing Chase Bank as the
caller she says and on the other end
hello ma'am this is Miss Barbara from
Chase ATM I'd like to know if it's okay
if I give you a new card and I said yes
a new debit card but she says the woman
told her before she could issue it she'd
need to verify Moss's identity by
sending her a text message and having
her read the numbers in the message back
to her over the phone and I would just
repeat those numbers to her and she'd
say that's great thank you so much Miss
muscle
your card was supposed to arrive in one
to two days but Moss says the next day
Ms Barbara called saying FedEx was
having trouble locating her home
something Moss says wasn't surprising to
her since she just moved over the next
week Miss Barbara called several times
Moss says each time saying there was a
problem with delivery of the card and
each time asking Moss to verify her
identity by reading back the numbers
from those text messages Moss finally
decided to go to the nearest bank branch
30 minutes from her home and it was here
she says a supervisor told her he looks
up at me and says oh no Deborah this has
been a very active card as a matter of
fact all the money that you had in there
is gone and you actually owe Chase 895
dollars that's how I was told that
somebody had taken all my money nearly
160 thousand dollars stolen it's a lot
of money
took me 12 years to get that money and
that was my life savings it turns out
those text messages Moss received they
were real texts sent from Chase Bank a
security measure known as two-factor
authentication used to verify among
other things wire transfers but in this
case the scammers tricked Moss into
giving them those numbers allowing them
to evade security and wire thousands of
dollars from Moss's account to their own
six wire transfers and amounts as high
as almost 48 thousand dollars in a
single week I don't even know what a
wire transfer was I've never done a wire
transfer in my whole life
Chase told Moss to file a police report
then a claim with the bank which she did
but five weeks later Chase denied her
claim and blamed her writing during our
review we found you did not take the
appropriate steps to protect your
account from theft or unauthorized use
Bank officials said they would not
reimburse her account my world fell
apart my whole world fell apart in
response to our questions J.P Morgan
Chase told us in a statement
unfortunately when scammers tricked Ms
Moss into sharing her personal
confidential information her account was
compromised but this former Federal
regulator says of the bank any way you
look at it they failed they failed her
David Weber teaches forensic accounting
at Salisbury University in Maryland and
is a certified fraud examiner is that
true the bank could have required her to
come in and sign the wire form in person
they left everything for her to be on
risk
and now they're saying they bear no
responsibility what's more he says those
two facts
two fedication system s aren't strong
enough this is happening hundreds and
thousands of times a day in the United
States using the exact same methods here
the two-factor authentication is not
strong enough to protect this customer
JPMorgan Chase told us each year they
invest hundreds of millions of dollars
in authentication risk models technology
and Associate client education to make
it harder for scammers to trick
customers but Moss says you think of
your bank as being someplace there you
put your money so that it's safe but
it's not safe it needs to change
now Chase Bank told us they tried to
contact Moss at the time with voicemails
and emails she said she never got any of
those but some tips from Chase Bank
about protecting yourself here do not
give out your ATM pin your passcodes to
anybody and please don't click on
suspicious links in emails or texts you
want to avoid that guys
oh gosh uh Anna I mean the key word
there is suspicious links how do you
know if a link is suspicious how do our
viewers know because the the scammers
got into the account because of that
initial click on a link that's what led
them in how is that prevented
I think you have to really look at these
text messages very carefully
um I've gotten them and they look really
real if you have any question at all
whether this is actually coming from the
bank and even if you don't frankly what
you can do is look at the back of your
card the number is on the back of your
card or go to the website and look for
the number call that number then ask say
hey I've got this text but I'm not
really sure if it's from you can you
tell me if it is or not
that's good advice there wow that's just
an awful story it's scary she's right
you do put your money in the bank
because you think it's going to be safer
than under the bed and in this case
doesn't appear that it was yeah all
right Anna thank you very much